Mohammed, he didn't do He didn't He was
a peaceful person. Like he was literally
known in in
in his time before he was a prophet,
before he ever claimed anything as a
Sadiq al-Amin. He before he
revealed that he got
that he got a message from God, he stood
up on a mountain, he said, "O people of
Mecca, if I said there was
army of people coming here to destroy
us, would you believe me?" And they
said, "Yes, you are a Sadiq al-Amin.
You're the most truthful truthful person
we know." So he didn't lie. That's He
like never lied. That's one of his
characteristics that we try to abide by.
And also um Mohammed was illiterate,
peace be upon him. He was illiterate. He
couldn't read or write. So
the fact that he had one of the most one
of the like most beautiful versions of
Arabic like I don't know what to I I
kind of want to call it poetry, but it's
the one of the most beautiful Arabic
writings in the world. One of the most
beautiful writings in general. The Quran
has it keeps its rhythm. It doesn't
break any grammatical rules in it. It
keeps a story. It can It can what's it
called? I saw videos on this other day.
It can have It can be talking about a
story and it can get bring in a whole
different story and the context will
make sense. The rhythm will stay.
Everything works with it. And he was
illiterate.
>> I would have a lot of disagreement with
that. I I I think that if we were to
look at a lot of examples, that there's
a lot of stuff in the Quran that it it
doesn't make sense. It's not clear. You
know what I'm saying?
>> Like what? Do you have an example? Sure.
So So look. So we have
We have for example So the the Quran
itself it claims to be clear. It claims
to be detailed and all these kind of
things, right? So a full explanation of
everything and stuff like that. Now, if
we go to certain verses in the Quran and
I'm not talking about out of context, I
mean in context.
Mhm. We there's some things that we it
won't make sense
um outside of like if we just read the
Quran itself it wouldn't make sense. So,
for example, so here's just one little
simple example that I like to use.
Chapter 17:1 it says, "Glorified be he
who who carried his servant by night
from the
invaluable inviolable place of worship I
guess that's the sec the sacred place of
worship to the farthest distant place of
worship. Um the neighborhood where of we
have blessed that we might show him our
tokens. He only he is the hearer the
seer. So, just based off of this and if
you want we can like continue to read
and stuff like that or if you need to
but based off of this
who is the servant that it's talking
about? Glorified be he the he is capital
for Allah that's what that's what he
usually means who carried a servant his
servant means Muhammad because this is
talking about the context of Isra wal
Miraj which is the
this is when the prophet this is when
God The night journey, right?
>> [clears throat]
>> So, where where is
>> Yeah, the night journey he Where does it
say that this is Muhammad? This it's the
context it's just obvious because
everyone knows the story. Right. It's
like one of the Where do you get the
story from though?
I've just been taught it by my parents
but like
if you read it in I feel like I don't
know about this specific thing but on my
side when I'm looking at my the app that
I use is called Aya Ayah.
It says exalted is he who took his
servant Prophet Muhammad Yeah, it puts
it in it puts it in parentheses, right?
It does say it put it in parentheses but
I feel like it's also capitalized or
wait the
oh okay here this is where it says it
says if you read it in Arabic it says
Ar-Rasul Ar-Rasul means messenger. Yeah.
That's messenger Muhammad which is Yeah,
I love wait wait wait hold on Ali hold
on hold on because Allah has a lot of
messengers, right? Muhammad's not just
not the only Rasul. Right? Abraham,
Moses, Jesus, they're all also
messengers. And others.
So, how do we know that this is talking
about Muhammad?
From Okay, let's I want to read further
into this because maybe it'll give a
clue, but I feel like this is like Oh,
it does give a clue. It definitely does.
If we go to the next verse or if you
want to read further If we go to the
next verse it mentions Moses.
Okay, so we gave unto Moses the
scripture.
All right, that's just so that's talking
about a separate thing. I can't give me
1 sec. I want to listen to this one so
>> Yeah, sure sure.
So, over here this what I'm seeing is
Okay, so I'm going to take a educated
guess. Over here it says is glorified be
who came to serve it. I bet in a certain
Hadith it explains this whole story
>> You're absolutely right.
>> And this one and over here it says it's
just saying his servant. Maybe it's hard
to tell of the context here, but you
also have to take into account the fact
that Prophet Muhammad reveals these
verses. So, it was him reciting, which
means that he probably said he said this
exact ayah he said this exact verse and
he told his companions or if one of the
if some of them didn't get it, which
they probably would, but if one of them
didn't get it probably would have said,
"Yes, he's talking about me." Like I
claimed You know how I And So so here's
the here's the point Ali. Here's the
point. Here's the point. The point is is
that you don't get that information from
the Quran, right? You have to go outside
of the Quran in order to make sense of
this verse. The Quran itself doesn't
make sense in this verse.
You know?
I want to say that when the prophet
revealed it, it definitely would have
made sense.
And it doesn't cuz the prophet the
prophet revealed it If someone came up
to you and they said glorified be to he
who carried his servant Mhm. from the
place and this is right before you have
to get the context cuz right before he
said this, I'm pretty sure at the time
of this revealing of this surah of this
chapter, he was telling all of his
companions about how he went to Masjid
al-Aqsa and all the way in Palestine.
>> you see
>> he reveals this right after it shows
him. So so notice how you have to get
you need Muhammad's explanation in order
to make a Quran verse make sense. You
cannot you just use the Quran to make
sense of the Quran here. You know what I
mean? You have to go outside of the
Quran for background information, for
details, you know what I'm saying? To
get the explanation of this verse. It
does not give you this information
itself. You have to go outside of it.
You know what I mean?
>> All right. I can I can see what you're
talking about. I can see how that can be
misleading, but
>> Yeah. So there there but there's a lot
of examples like this, but that that's
not the only problem here. So notice how
Okay. So notice how you said it says
glorified be he, right? Now obviously we
would assume that the he is Allah.
Right? The he would be God. That's what
we assume. Let's say we're not assuming
anything. It just says glorified be he.
In the Arabic there's no capitals,
right? You you it's you read Arabic a
little bit. So there's no capital. So we
can't rely on this. But so the the
Arabic is glorified be he who carried
his servant by night from the sacred
place of worship to the farthest place
of worship. The neighborhood where we
have blessed that we might show him
our tokens.
He, only he is the hearer, the seer.
Mhm. So still talking about him, the
servant. It says we might show him our
tokens, the servant. It continues to say
he, he only he is the hearer and the
seer. It seems to be calling the servant
the he the hearer and the seer. All
right. Subhana Wait. so I can't I want
to make sense of this in Arabic because
I know there's a bunch of cases when
cuz the thing about me is I don't speak
the pure the Quranic Arabic, so I have I
have an app where the person recites it
and that can like get the context from
his recitation.
>> Yeah, it's okay, man. Yeah, we take your
time, man. Yeah, you can pull up the
recitation and everything. Take your
time. On my side, what I'm hearing is
Subhanalladhi asra al-Mi'raj, the person
who took his servant. So, it doesn't
really say he there to Masjid al-Haram.
It says to the close place and the far
place. Close place is referring to
Masjid al-Haram which where he was at
the time. You don't know that. And the
far place You don't know that.
The time where it was revealed is this
time, so I feel like You don't know that
either. You don't You don't know where
>> do know that. That's when he revealed
it, which means that's what he's talking
about to the close place to the far
place. Wait, wait. That That would
That's assuming that it's talking about
Muhammad himself. You So, I'm just
saying by the by the Quran verse, you do
not know where the sacred place is or
the furthest
>> It says to the It says to the far place.
Uh-huh. So, yeah, that's It's talking
about
It says right there where it says it
says the on your thing it says
the far distant place of worship. He
took you from
So, his servant Yeah, yeah, yeah. It
says glorified be he. Praise the person
or player
Praise he who carried a servant from the
place of inviolable worship to the place
of far distant worship. Mhm. It says
whose surroundings we blessed to show
him of our signs. And indeed, he is the
hearing. So, on your side, we might show
him of our tokens. I don't know what
this has to do with tokens. I don't even
Yeah, I think it's like that. I think
it's
I think it's probably like blessings or
something really. Uh But it says it says
we took him by night Mhm.
from al-Masjid al-Haram to Masjid
al-Aqsa. Masjid al-Haram is the Kaaba,
You know the one in where he was at the
time. That's your assumption.
>> He was there when it was revealed. It's
not like this isn't an assumption.
That's literally where he was You can
look it up. This is a Meccan verse. You
don't know that.
>> in a Medinian verse, but he was there.
>> is my point is from the Quran itself you
don't you don't know that Muhammad's
talking about himself. He could be
talking about Moses or something.
Another another What you were talking
about before that you said inviolable
place of worship. I think he's It's
saying inviolable here because
inviolable is talking about and he says
He uses two different words. So the
Kaaba it's the most sacred place. So he
uses that inviolable that means you
can't violate it. And this is why this
is one of the reasons why like only
Muslims are
allowed in Mecca. This is where the
Kaaba is. It's not allowed to be
violated. So that gives the context that
it's being the Kaaba. Did you know that?
>> Okay, so yeah, I guess it's not an
assumption. Ali, it is an assumption
because you're not
You're assuming that the sacred place of
worship is the Kaaba. It doesn't say
that. It says the What your says It says
the inviolable place. Well, yeah, but
you're assuming just take it for sacred.
We're going to take this for sacred? The
word inviolable means not able to be
violated. So
>> sacred it's sacred. It's it's good. It's
good.
>> most sacred place
is the Kaaba. That's the most sacred
place.
>> Where does Where does it say that?
This is common knowledge. This is what
I'm being a Muslim means.
>> So do you see how you have to assume
your common knowledge and what you and
your tradition and plug it into the
Quran for it to make sense.
You don't get that from the Quran.
>> I [snorts] see what you mean. So I guess
I guess you could say that. But like at
the at the same time
So you can like if say there was a
person who like they knew Arabic and
they didn't know anything else. If you
give them any single book they wouldn't
know what to say. You have to have some
type of background information to have
the Quran.
>> Very good. So, that's my point. My point
is is that the Quran needs help.
It needs It's not It within its own self
is not fully detailed. It's not fully
explained. There are some details that
it lacks, some explanations that it
doesn't provide. You have to go outside
of the Quran in order to get certain
explanations. That's all I'm saying.
All right. I got I can agree with I can
agree with you there that if somebody
read it
Because if you read the Quran wholly,
like the whole thing, I bet in other
places it would say that. But like I'm
I'm judging from this only first, I
could see what you mean. Now, I
guarantee and I'll give you I'll give
you a chance to like look into the
Quran, like check this out later on when
we when we get off and stuff like that.
Check this out later on. You're not
going to find it anywhere.
What you'll What you'll find is people,
and especially when you look at these
articles and stuff like that cuz I've
looked into this before I've come and
made this argument, I
I myself made sure that all the boxes
were checked. I needed to check was
there anywhere in the Quran, not just in
this chapter, but anywhere in the Quran,
does it mention where the sacred place
is, where the farthest place is?
Uh does it ever mention again this night
journey and say it's Muhammad
specifically or like allude to that, you
know? Nowhere. Nowhere in the Quran does
it give you any details on this.
And this is the best we get right here,
you know? All right.
Uh No, I I admit that in this in this in
the
the Quran has places where you need
context. Yes. Uh at this but I feel like
Okay, so I want to like make sure I'm
not saying anything by saying it needs
context cuz maybe that's like one of the
rules. Well, no. Look, look. You And
this is this is another problem that I
have with the Quran, okay? Is that So,
your Quran says in chapter 3 verse 7
that there are some verses that are
clear and some verses that are unclear
and only Allah knows
>> Oh, so it does say that. So, okay. Thank
God. I thought I just got unproved.
No, you're fine.
So, so the Quran does say that there are
some verses that are clear, there are
some verses that are unclear,
and only Allah knows the meaning. Those
of knowledge, those scholars of
knowledge just affirm and say we believe
in it all, right? But only Allah knows
the true meaning of these ambiguous
verses.
Oh, that's good.
But
there's a problem with that.
Mhm. Cuz though, you know, you kind of
got a relief there, but there's actually
a problem.
The problem is is that elsewhere in the
Quran
it claims to be fully detailed about
everything.
Where does it say that? So, yeah. Let me
um
And after we look at this one, I want to
see where the one where it says the cuz
I want to see the one where it says it's
some of it's going to be understand,
some of it is not. Yeah, okay. Did you
want to go there first or Mm, okay. So,
yeah, let's go for there first. That
That makes Okay, we'll go there first.
All right. Chapter 3 verse 7.
That That does make sense. He is the one
who has revealed to you, oh prophet, the
the book of which some verses are
precise. They are the foundation of the
book, while others are elusive. Those
with deviant hearts follow the elusive
verses seeking to spread doubt through
their false interpretations, but none
grasp the full meaning except Allah.
I guess this is
what?
All right. Okay. As for those well
grounded in knowledge, they say we
believe in this Quran, it is all from
our Lord, but none will be mindful of
this except people of reason. All right.
>> Right.
So, so this is pretty clear, right? It's
pretty clear. There's some verses that
are clear,
>> [cough]
>> precise, some verses that are not so
clear. They're elusive. They're Only
Allah knows the meaning of these verses,
right? Exactly.
>> So,
so So, is a problem
This is a problem. It wouldn't be a
problem if this was the only verse. If
this was consistent in the Quran and
this is what it said, no problem.
Certain verses are clear, some verses
ambiguous, you know, Allah knows Allah.
He knows best, right? Uh we can get some
from the scholars, some from uh
interpretations, stuff like that, but
this says only Allah knows the meaning.
Now, but here's a problem.
The problem is when the Quran makes the
opposite statement.
You can't have verses that are clear and
unclear, right?
At the same while at the same time
saying that the Quran is fully detailed
and explained about everything.
Those two statements are contradictory.
They both can't be true, right?
So, so here's the here's what the verse
says. And this is chapter 12, Surah
Yusuf, the very last verse, 111. The
very last one. All right.
Yusuf Give me
one second if my computer would just
stop. Guys, uh make sure you guys are
are are leaving a like. If you're on
Facebook watching, make sure you're
leaving a reaction and liking the uh
liking the video, reacting to it. And uh
please uh also pray for Ali. Pray for
our friend Ali. He's a good young young
brother who is is down for these
conversations, respectful, and things of
this nature. Seems to be honest. So,
let's pray for him and pray that more
like him can continue to come around,
okay? But, make sure you guys are
smashing that like button. Are you got
it?
Yeah. All right. In their history,
verily there is a lesson for men of
understanding. It is no invented story,
but a confirmation of existing scripture
and detailed explanation of everything,
and a guidance and a mercy to folk who
believe. So, you see how it says that
it's a detailed explanation of
everything, right?
So, that means that
it there there are no verses that are
ambiguous or unclear. It can't have
clear and unclear verses while at the
same time saying that it's a detailed
explanation of everything.
That's a literal contradiction.
All right.
On my side it says there was certainly
in their stories a lesson for those
understanding. Never was it a narration
invented, but a confirmation of what was
before it and detailed and a detailed
explanation of all things and guidance
and mercy for for people who believe.
So,
on it's saying on my side that this is
what it's talking when it says the
things when it when it says things in
general, it's talking about that it
says, you know how it's saying the
confirmation of what was before talking
about like the Injil and Taurats and
Bible and Torah. Yeah.
Giving an explanation to all things
explained in the Bible and the Torah.
Okay. So, if
>> That's what I'm seeing here. That's what
I infer. Like this is the first time
I've seen this ayah cuz I don't have
this I don't have the Quran memorized
yet inshallah.
>> It's okay, man. I'm a I'm a I'm a
English Hafiz. You got me here. I got
you.
So,
so okay. So, now let's take this
interpretation
that
the Quran it's not saying that the Quran
itself within its own self is detailed
explanation of all things in the Quran,
but it's a detailed explanation of all
things in the previous scripture.
All right?
>> Of all the misguided things of the all
the things that need explanation in the
whole in the It doesn't say that. It
says all things.
We can't we we can't qualify it if the
Quran doesn't qualify. The Quran says
all things. We can't add.
>> All right, sure. Let's Yeah, let's try
that. Sure.
>> Okay. So, if the Quran is a detailed
explanation of all things concerning the
previous scripture,
then at least whatever whatever the the
Quran mentions. Whatever the Quran
repeats or mentions from the previous
scriptures, it should be completely
detailed about it. Completely explained
it, completely detailed about it, right?
Mhm. [clears throat]
Okay. So, this is where now if we
investigate this claim to see if this is
true or not.
For example, if we go to the beginning,
the Quran mentions the story of Adam and
his wife.
Right? It mentions that story, okay?
Their fall, them eating the fruit, all
this kind of stuff.
But
does the Quran tell you who Adam's wife
is?
The answer is no.
>> But yeah, yeah, yeah, we could try to
look it up.
What I'm from from what I'm seeing here,
it says it doesn't, but like I said, it
gives it it said over here that it gives
a detailed explanation about what the
Bible said before. So, if the Bible said
their name if the Bible said it, then I
guess the the Quran doesn't have to say
it. But it says all things.
>> Because it's giving just an explanation.
No, it says all
>> explanation. If you have information and
you're going to explain it, you don't
have to
say the information you already had
before.
Well, if the people don't already have
this information before and the Quran is
explaining all things that are in the
previous scripture, then all those
things need to be mentioned.
Unless just don't say that then. If
you're not an explanation of all things
concerning the previous scripture, don't
make that claim. Just say that you
explain things from the previous
scripture. May not may maybe not
everything, but you explain some things
in the previous scripture.
The trouble is that it says all things.
All right. Are these are these things
lives recorded?
What?
>> Like can I rewatch the lives? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. All right, cuz I want to
maybe come like later and I want to
watch all these and talk to somebody of
knowledge like an actual scholar. Yeah.
So I can see if any of these things make
sense. Absolutely. So so I'm going to
and I'm going to tell you the answers
that you're going to get.
>> [snorts]
>> These are the answers and it's actually
similar to the explanation that you
already gave that one
that
so in the view that the Quran is talking
about itself not just about the previous
scriptures but everything in the Quran
that it mentions is a is a detailed
explanation of everything in the Quran.
So you're what you'll find in like the
tafseers or maybe an Imam will tell you
that it's detailed about everything
necessary for your guidance. It's
detailed about everything that's that
you need to know, you know, this type of
stuff. Right? Now, these will be these
will be fine answers, Ali, if
the Quran didn't say it's a detailed
explanation about all things.
If it said it's a detailed explanation
about things you need to know, things
that's necessary for your guidance, then
they would have a point.
But that's not what it says.